hello I'm in from Australia I love this
country so much I've been traveling
around with my fiance it's a man sorry
ladies wrong tree stop barking his name
is Karan which is so close to a name and
we're women together for like eight
years we're trying for a dog and I ate
well I must appeal I haven't told him it
I is it is a small amount of time it's a
long time but I'll be honest we don't
know how we've lasted that long we've
lost a lot longer than a lot of our
friends so they will ask us sometimes
out of nowhere they'll just be like
what's the secret though we don't know
what doing some people ask us we can
just make [ __ ] up or just blow well it's
just about making sacrifices or we have
a date no runs away or joined a Fight
Club you know like like we lie if you
want the truth is it I think the truth
is anyone the truth of how to have a
happy long-lasting modern relationship
just try this guys just lie to each
other just live this lie and lie lie lie
like there is no tomorrow tell them
there is no tomorrow they don't not my I
am I think lying the very important part
to a relationship I read this study
recently when they believe that the
average human person lives 19 times a
day late in that amazing and that's a
lie I made that up but but it sounds
true and that's what my truth is but I'm
a millennial person I'm a Gen Y person
Jenny as well as the children refused to
call I read this other study
sociologists believe that our generation
Generation Y is the most useless
self-obsessed self-absorbed generation
so far and I didn't know what they meant
by that study that study hurt my
feelings but I get this contra I was one
of like what are we going to be
remembered for our generation like what
are we passing up think about this right
what are our heirlooms gonna be like
this is the Samsung Galaxy I met your
grandmother on you know what I am
I think my heirloom all the time all the
time because I were an heirloom I wear
this ring this ring is hundreds of years
old that's been passed down to all the
men in my family and I'm the closest
thing we have to that right now holding
on to our times and my sister
transitions you know but I know so
Stephen Joe how do you think about this
a lot I don't really believe in gender I
don't really think I kind of identify
the male or a female
I think identifies like a fun aunt
Jermaine's ofoh gobble what wines you
know that um you know that aren't we all
had growing up who was a lot of fun but
when you think about it now you're like
oh she might have had some personal
problems you know that one I did I
recently I got diagnosed it's a fun word
I got diagnosed with a severe anxiety
disorder surprised but you seem so
balanced Thank You Man I am i like the
term anxiety to sort of though i want to
give that a different spin I prefer to
think of it like I'm celiac but within
tolerance to hope you know and
and statistically there's people in the
room that have mental illness you know
it's all about making it fun for
yourself I like the Christmas light last
year which is when it always is I put
all my medication in an advent calendar
ah every day I'm feeling safer and then
and then on Christmas Day I just don't
take it he's risen but because of Hogan
the my anxiety I don't sleep very well
until very recently I've been enjoying
this state quite a bit
oh just so I can go to sleep in out I
just make a little tiny bit of meth no
it is a little bit I just hit the gym no
I mean are there spiders in my skin but
I think I look at night II know I've
started um smoking marijuana you can
tell him quite new to marijuana by the
way so I used the word marijuana soon as
I get to the old lady Jane its recent
madness no but I am but my fiancee we're
very kind of different people we've been
together for eight years as I said and
what he's quite an outdoorsy person he
wanted to do this thing last year he
wanted to go camping and I did not want
to go camping but relationships much
like worshipping Satan are about
sacrifices
so we'd found a middle ground we decided
to go glamping this is why you tried to
sell it to me though he was like come on
it'll be great we'll be like Scouts oh
no I was now as never a scout because my
parents you know loved me
well I like like I imagine being a scout
like yeah let's send a bunch of kids
into the forest with a bunch of 40 year
old men in short shorts what could go
wrong I got this one for tying a rope
this one for climbing a tree and this
one for keeping a secret
[Applause]